skincare routine honestly it's my all  meat diet there's also this moisturizer  i use that's probably worth seven  dollars called cerave it's the best  moisturizer i've ever used so i  moisturize all over my face before i go  to bed i use lanolin as well which is  like some horrible like sheep oil it's  something gross but it works really well  i also use a hyaluronic acid moisturizer  before i go to bed but my skin is mostly  my diet like if i get sick my skin will  break out of bed if i drink too much  it'll break out a bit if i eat chicken  or too much honey it'll break out a bit  isn't that sad oh well whatever no it's  kind of sad actually chicken wings are  great